Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Her beauty, as we are told, was in itself not altogether incomparable, nor such as to strike those who saw her. But converse with her had an irresistible charm, and her presence, combined with the persuasiveness of her discourse and the character, which was somehow diffused about her behaviour towards others, had something stimulating about it. There was sweetness also in the tones of her voice,
感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。想要每周收听独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。正如我们所知，她的美貌本身并不完全是无与伦比的，也不足以惊艳到那些见到她的人。但与她交谈有一种不可抗拒的魅力，她的存在，加上她言谈的说服力，以及她对人行为举止中自然流露出的个性，带有某种激励人心的东西。她的声音也带着甜美，
and her tongue, like an instrument of many strings, she could readily turn to whatever language she pleased. So that is the historian Plutarch talking about Cleopatra VII, the subject of this miniseries. And Tom, that's one of the only real descriptions that we have of Cleopatra's appearance and personality. It's not just sort of propagandistic invective. And we have a question from Dr. Dan the Bandage Man, one of our listeners, asking about Cleopatra's beauty, because of course she's probably the best known character in history for her looks. Yeah. But,
而且她的舌头就像一件多弦乐器，她可以轻而易举地切换到她喜欢任何语言。这就是历史学家普鲁塔克在谈论克娄巴特拉七世，也就是我们这个迷你系列的主角。托姆，这是我们仅有的关于克娄巴特拉外貌和性格的真实描述之一。这不仅仅是那种宣传性质的谩骂。我们有一位听众，Dr. Dan the Bandage Man，提问关于克娄巴特拉的美貌，因为她当然可能是历史上因外表而最广为人知的人物。是的。但是，
but what's the truth there? Do you think this is, do you think she, I mean, Plutarch says she wasn't particularly beautiful. So the story, I mean, the image,
但真相是什么呢？你认为这是，你觉得她，我的意思是，普鲁塔克说她长得并不是特别漂亮。所以这个故事，我的意思是，这个形象，
the image of her, certainly in the 19th century, she, she, she becomes the toast of kind of symbolists and decadence. And she's cast as this kind of exquisitely beautiful, predatory vampire-ess who kills courtiers. She sleeps with a man every night and then kills him in the morning, all this kind of stuff. And the assumption
她的形象，当然在19世纪，她，她，她成为了象征主义者和颓废派追捧的对象。她被塑造为那种极其美貌、掠夺成性的吸血鬼式女性，会杀死朝臣。她每天晚上和一个男人睡觉，然后在早晨杀死他，诸如此类的事情。人们的假设是
is that she's very, very sexual and she's very, very beautiful. And actually, I think neither of those things are true. She seems to have been, I mean, not particularly stunningly beautiful. If you look at the coins, she has quite a kind of hawk nose. And I mean, she doesn't look absolutely stunning. And as Plutarch describes her, her fascination seems to lie not in her looks so much as in her character and i think that that you know it's the um age cannot wither her nor custom stale her infinite variety that you get in the in shakespeare's portrayal of her and there's this wonderful um description that ena barbus who is anthony's sidekick henna barbus domitius henna barbus the original um and he he's trying to
她非常非常性感，也非常非常美丽。但实际上，我认为这两点都不是真的。她似乎，我的意思是，并不是特别惊艳的美丽。如果你看硬币，她的鼻子相当鹰钩。我的意思是，她看起来绝对谈不上惊艳。正如普鲁塔克所描述的，她的迷人之处似乎不在于她的外表，而在于她的性格。你知道，莎士比亚对她的刻画中有这样的话：“岁月不能使她枯萎，陈规不能使她陈腐，她千变万化，无穷无尽”。这里有一个绝妙的描写，安东尼的死党恩诺巴布斯——多米蒂乌斯·恩诺巴布斯，原本的——他在努力
explain to someone what it is about Cleopatra that makes her so compelling. And he says, I saw her once hop 40 paces through the public street, and having lost her breath, she spoke and panted that she did make defect perfection. And I think that brilliantly gets something that's there in Plutarch. The sense that there is a kind of fascination that's not dependent on you know conventional beauty it's just that she is a very very compelling person and and i think that as we you know we'll explore on the question of is she a massively sexual person as far as she as we know she only ever slept with two men yeah and both
向某人解释克娄巴特拉究竟有什么魔力让她如此引人注目。他说：“我曾见她在大街上跳着步子小跑四十步，由于喘不过气，她说话时直喘粗气，竟把缺点化为了完美。”我认为这绝妙地捕捉到了普鲁塔克文字中的某种精髓。那种魅力并不依赖于传统的美貌，而是因为她是一个非常有吸引力的人。正如我们将在节目中探讨的，关于她是否是一个极度性感的人——据我们所知，她一生中只和两个男人睡过，是的，
those men happen to be the most powerful men in the world but they're both they're both much older men and much more powerful men they're both romans and she knows how to you know she she tailors her present herself presentation yes to to suit what she knows about their respective characters do you think even though i mean as we said in our first episode everything we we know about, well, almost everything that's written down in narrative form about Cleopatra comes from the Romans and comes from her enemies. Despite that, don't you agree that you can,
而且这两个男人恰好是世界上最有权势的男人，但他们都比她大得多，权势大得多，而且都是罗马人。她懂得如何——她会根据自己对他们各自性格的了解，来调整和展现自己，是的。你是否认为，尽管正如我们在第一集所说的那样，我们所知道的一切——或者说几乎所有关于克娄巴特拉的叙事形式的文字记录——都来自罗马人，来自她的敌人？尽管如此，你不觉得在字里行间的缝隙中，你还是能感受到那种个人魅力吗？
sort of bleeding out between the gaps, you get a sense of the charisma? Absolutely. So Plutarch, he talks about, I think it's his grandfather, knew someone who worked at the court of Cleopatra. That's right, Philotas, I think his name was. A medical student. Yes. And he talks about how they have banquets all the time. They're constantly cooking in the kitchens. And this is simply so that Cleopatra and Antony can have a banquet whenever they want. But you do get the sense there of a living tradition. The romance and the power and the charisma of Cleopatra has kind of survived to be something
绝对是的。所以普鲁塔克提到，我记得是他的祖父认识一个在克娄巴特拉宫廷工作过的人。没错，我想他叫菲洛塔斯。一个医学生。是的。他提到他们一直在举行宴会。厨房里总是在做饭。这仅仅是为了让克娄巴特拉和安东尼随时都能办宴会。但你在其中确实能感受到一种活生生的传统。克娄巴特拉的浪漫、权力和魅力就这样流传下来，并在100或150年后被普鲁塔克记录下来。
to be repeated down the generations and to be reported by Plutarch 100, 150 years after. I'm so glad you mentioned that because I think that's such a lovely story because so many of the Roman histories, there's a sense of them adhering to formulae and propagandistic formulae. And that bit when Plutarch says, my grandfather knew somebody called Philotas who was then a medical student
我很高兴你提到这一点，因为我觉得这是一个非常可爱的故事，因为许多罗马历史都有遵循某种公式和宣传公式的倾向。当普鲁塔克说“我的祖父认识一个叫菲洛塔斯的医学生，当时他去过厨房”之类的话时，我的意思是，这其实太具有现实感了，不是吗？这是一个非常可爱的细节，完全展现了那种奢华。是的。不是吗？这是一个非常可爱的细节。这一切都关乎克娄巴特拉宫廷的奢华。我认为这意味着，当普鲁塔克说她拥有这种魅力和力量时，你会觉得这些是代代相传的真实记录。而且她一定拥有那种力量。
and went to the kitchens and all that. I mean, it's so contemporary actually, isn't it? It's such a lovely detail and it's all about the luxury. Yeah. Isn't it? It's such a lovely detail. And it's all about the luxury of Cleopatra's court. And I think it means that when Plutarch says that she had this charisma and this power, you feel that those are authentic reports that have been handed down. And she must have had that power.
是的。仅仅因为她所做过的事。你知道，她辉煌事业的宏大规模。而且她也非常非常聪明。普鲁塔克说她会说，是九种语言吗？诸如此类吧，是的。有趣的是，其中似乎不包括拉丁语。埃塞俄比亚人、穴居人、希伯来人、阿拉伯人、叙利亚人、米底人和帕提亚人。普鲁塔克接着说，据说她精通
Yeah. Simply because of what she'd done. You know, the extraordinary scale of her career. And she's very, very clever as well. So Plutarch says that she spoke, is it nine languages? Something like that, yeah. Of which I think Latin, interestingly, is not one. The Ethiopians, the Troglodytes, the Hebrews, Arabians, Syrians, Medes, and Parthians. And Plutarch then says, it is said that she knew the speech
许多其他民族的语言，尽管她之前的埃及国王甚至没有费心去学习本土语言。是的，所以她是第一个说埃及话的人，埃及语。对此唯一的合理解释大概就是她很聪明。我的意思是，她生活在被图书馆、博物馆和所有这些学者包围的环境中。但我认为她同时——我们在上一集的末尾也讨论过这一点——她是一个身处男人世界的年轻女性。她意识到，如果她能将自己塑造成伊西斯女神的形象——这位统治着尼罗河、统治着这个古老国家生命节奏的女神——那么她就能激发出深厚的忠诚度。而她的前辈们——那些驻扎在亚历山大（这座依附于埃及的异域希腊城市）的统治者们——从未能做到这一点。事实也正是如此。
many other peoples also although the kings of egypt before her had not even made an effort to learn the native language yeah so she's the first to speak speak egyptian egyptian the only explanation for that presumably is that she's clever i mean she's living in surrounded by the library and the museum and all these scholars and but I think she also, we're talking about this at the end of the previous episode. She is a young woman in a man's world. And she is recognizing that if she can cast herself as the image of the goddess Isis, the goddess who presides over the Nile, who presides over the rhythms of life in this ancient country, then she will be able to draw on wellsprings of loyalty that her forebears camped out in Alexandria, this alien Greek city kind of attached to Egypt, had never been able to do. And that is exactly what happens.
她把这一点发挥得淋漓尽致。让我们回到正题，所以她成功了。我们在上一集的结尾讲到她的继承权。公元前51年，她成为了法老，或者与她的弟弟托勒密十三世共同执政。你承诺过我们会讲很多地缘政治背景，因为我们要进入罗马内战了——凯撒和庞培之间的内战。她的待办事项里有一堆各种各样的问题。因此，尼罗河的水位是一个大问题，雨水是否充足——是的，我的意思是税收水平，——她的父亲曾
She makes incredible play with it. Let's get, so she succeeded. We ended the last episode really with her succession. She becomes pharaoh or joint pharaoh with her brother Ptolemy XIII in 51 BC. And you promised us lots of geopolitical context because we're getting into the Roman Civil War, the civil war between Caesar and Pompey. She has all kinds of problems in her kind of in-tray. So the level of the nile is a big issue whether there's going to be enough rain yeah i mean the level of taxation um her father has
将德拉克马贬值，作为他试图偿还所有这些债务等手段的一部分。所以她还面临着你之前提到过的问题——她的弟弟和她弟弟的大臣们在密谋反对她，试图把她挤走。那么，她是如何应对这一切混乱局面的呢？这真是一团糟，不是吗？她父亲的朝臣们显然认为他们两个都应该当傀儡。显而易见，克娄巴特拉是绝不会配合扮演这个角色的，因此其中有两个人尤为突出：一个是名叫阿基拉斯的军人，
devalued the drachma as part of his way of kind of trying to pay off all these debts and stuff so she's also got the issue which you alluded to before of her brother and her brother's ministers conspiring against her and trying to sort of force her out so sort of how does how does she deal with all this this this i mean it's a mess isn't it her father's courtiers clearly think that uh both of them should be puppets it's evident that cleopatra is not going to to play this part uh and so there are two in particular there's a guy called achillas who is a military man yeah and there's a guy called pathillas, who is a military man. Yeah. And there's a guy called Pothinus, who regular listeners to the show will be pleased to know is a eunuch. Well, he's, so he's the man who you see, if ever you watch a program like Cleopatra, you know, he's always the man.
还有一个叫波提努斯的家伙。节目常客听到这里一定会高兴，他是个太监。好吧，他就是那种人在你看像《克娄巴特拉》这样的节目时会看到的——你知道，他总是那种人。
We don't know what he looked like. We don't know anything like that. But casting directors, without fail, say, get the fattest man in the agency. Shave his head. Yes. And make him really sinister and simpering and effeminate. And he, Pothinus, is always played that way isn't he yes absolutely um so cleopatra basically gets forced out of alexandria and she goes off with her her younger sister asinue to try and raise troops in in syria and
我们不知道他长什么样。我们对这些一无所知。但选角导演们无一例外地说：“去经纪公司找最胖的男人，把他的头剃光，对，让他看起来阴险、谄媚、脂粉气十足。”而他，波提努斯，总是被塑造成这个样子，不是吗？是的，绝对是。所以克娄巴特拉基本上被逐出了亚历山大，她带着她的妹妹阿尔西诺伊一起前往叙利亚去招募军队，
she comes down to uh to sinai and she kind of raises tribes there. And so there's a town called Pelusium, which is basically guards. It's the gateway to Egypt. And Cleopatra is lurking beyond Pelusium with her forces. And her brother Ptolemy XIII is under the thumb of all these various sinister ministers in Alexandria. And so it looks as though Egypt is going to erupt into civil war. But she's blocked there, by the way just yeah she's blocked she's blocked by the army because in the previous episode we talked about that guy aulus gabinius who had recapped and his men are still there aren't they the gabinians they're mercenaries and sort of they they're supposedly to some of
然后她来到了西奈半岛，并在那里招募了当地部落。有一个叫佩鲁西姆的小镇，它实际上是一个防御工事，是通往埃及的门户。克娄巴特拉正率领着她的部队潜伏在佩鲁西姆外围。而她的弟弟托勒密十三世则被亚历山大形形色色阴险的大臣们所掌控。因此，埃及似乎一触即发就要爆发内战。不过她在那里被挡住了，顺便说一下，是的，
them are germans and some of them are norsemen. And they've just been sort of hanging around in Egypt, sort of wenching, falling out of taverns, attacking people in the street, just making a nuisance of themselves. They're like the sort of 1970s football hooligans on tour. And the Egyptians can't get rid of them. And they are serving in Ptolemy's army. And they're basically blocking the way of Pelusia so she can't get past into Egypt. So that's the situation in Egypt. It's kind of
她被军队挡住了。因为我们在上一集里聊过那个叫奥卢斯·加比尼乌斯的人，他曾重新征服过埃及，而他的手下——加比尼安人——仍然留在那里，不是吗？他们是雇佣兵，其中一部分人据说据说是日耳曼人，还有一些是诺斯人。他们就一直在埃及闲晃，寻欢作乐，从酒馆里摇摇晃晃地走出来，在街上袭击路人，到处惹是生非。他们就像是上世纪70年代到处巡回的足球流氓。埃及人拿他们没辙。他们在托勒密的军队里服役，基本上把守着通往佩鲁西姆的道路，所以她无法进入埃及。这就是当时埃及的形势。这简直是
incipient civil war, but that is very much a sideshow for what meanwhile is going on in the broader Mediterranean, which is that Julius Caesar has crossed the Rubicon. And if you want the background to that, we've done two episodes on the buildup to Caesar crossing the Rubicon. Pompey has taken command of what he sees as the kind of the constitutional legitimate role. He stands at the head of the vast majority of the Senate. They have fled Rome. They've crossed the Adriatic. They've gone to Greece. Caesar has made sure of Spain. He's made sure of Italy. He then crosses with his fleet to Greece. He's vastly outnumbered. He ends up meeting with Pompey's armies at a place called Pharsalus. And against the odds, he beats Pompey. Why does he beat Pompey, Tom, just very quickly?
一触即发的内战，但这与同时在更广阔的地中海地区发生的事情相比，只算是个插曲。那就是尤利乌斯·凯撒已经跨过了卢比孔河。如果你想了解这背后的背景，我们曾做过两期关于凯撒跨越卢比孔河前奏的节目。庞培接管了他认为具有宪法合法性的角色。他站在绝大多数元老院成员的前面。他们逃离了罗马，横渡亚得里亚海去了希腊。凯撒已经稳固了西班牙，稳固了意大利。随后他率舰队渡海前往希腊。他的兵力处于绝对劣势，最终在法萨卢斯与庞培的军队交锋。出乎意料的是，他击败了庞培。托姆，为什么他能击败庞培，简单说说？
He's a better general. He's a cleverer, subtler general. Pompey is overconfident. And Caesar is at the head of men who have been following him for years and years, who've had absolute confidence in him, whose morale is sky high, who believe that they can do anything. Pompey is very much kind of resting on his laurels. He's drawing on a reputation that by this point is a decade and more old, and he doesn't have the legions to hand. So this had been pointed out to him in the buildup to the Rubicon, and Pompey had said, well, I just have to stamp my foot and legions will emerge from out of the soil of Italy. But it didn't work like that. Caesar's legions are just too proficient. Caesar is too, you know, they're too battle honed. And so Pompey loses, he flees the battlefield, and he then has to decide, well,
他是一位更好的统帅。他是一位更聪明、更狡猾的统帅。庞培过于自信。而凯撒率领的是那些追随了他多年、对他有着绝对信心、士气高昂、坚信自己无所不能的士兵。庞培则很大程度上在吃老本。他靠的是十年前甚至更久远的声誉，而且他手头没有足够的军团。所以在跨越卢比孔河之前，就有人向他指出过这一点，而庞培却说：“我只要跺一下脚，意大利的土地上就会涌现出无数军团。”但事实并非如此。凯撒的军团太精锐了。凯撒太——你知道的，他们经过了太多的战火淬炼。所以庞培战败了，他逃离了战场，然后他必须决定：
what am I going to do? And because he is the great conqueror of the East, he is the man who had brought much of the Near East under Roman power, who has kings across the Near East as his clients, he assumes that he can draw on them. And so he thinks, well, who is the richest? Who is the most useful of these royal clients? It's the king of Egypt. So he decides he will go to Egypt. He will go to Alexandria.
我该怎么办？因为他是东方伟大的征服者，是将近东大部分地区置于罗马权势之下的人，在近东各地都有以他为附庸的国王，他认为自己可以依靠这些人。因此他想，谁是最富有的人？谁是这些皇家附庸中最有用的人？是埃及国王。所以他决定去埃及，去亚历山大。
He will throw his weight around. He will pull rank and he will get enough money to raise money, to raise troops to go and have another crack at Caesar. So that's not a bad strategy when you think about it, is it? He's lost Pharsalus, but he knows that the Egyptians owe him because he'd always been very close to Auletes, Cleopatra's father. He knows that Egypt is torn apart by this incipient civil war. So he can kind of go in as the strongman. And basically, he knows there's a
他要去摆谱、耍大牌，筹集足够的资金来招募军队，好跟凯撒再决雌雄。仔细想想，这倒不是个坏策略，对吧？他在法萨卢斯战败了，但他知道埃及人欠他人情，因为他一直与克娄巴特拉的父亲奥勒斯保持着非常亲密的关系。他知道埃及正被这场一触即发的内战撕裂。所以他可以以强人的姿态介入。基本上，他知道那里有一个
boy king yeah so pompey just kind of thinks well this is this is great unfortunately he is the strong man he sees himself as a strong man it never crosses his mind that the fact that he's lost means that suddenly his image is no longer that of a strong man but of an absolute loser so there's this famous scene isn't there where um so Ptolemy XIII, the boy king, Cleopatra's still out there in the sort of the edge of the doctor. Beyond the Elysium, yeah. The boy king's ministers, they have this meeting and they say, what are we going to do? Pompey's coming. And supposedly there's a guy who's his tutor, Theodotus of Chios, I think it is, Tom, who I describe in my book as an oily man.
少年国王，是的。所以庞培就觉得，太棒了。不幸的是，他自认为是强人，却从未转过弯来：自己战败的事实意味着，他的形象不再是一个强人，而是一个彻头彻尾的失败者。这里有一个著名的场景，不是吗？当时托勒密十三世——那个少年国王——而克娄巴特拉还在外面，在那个地区边缘。在佩鲁西姆之外，是的。少年国王的大臣们召开了一场会议，讨论该怎么办。庞培要来了。据说有个家伙是他的家庭教师，叫希俄斯的西奥多图斯，我想是吧，托姆，我在书里把他描述为一个油腔滑调的人。
Not dealing in stereotypes. No, well, he behaves in a very, I don't know anything about Chios. I mean, they may be very unoily for all I know, but he behaves in a very oily way because he basically says, well, you know, if we accept Pompey, we make ourselves Julius Caesar's enemies, and Pompey will just boss us around and be a pain. If we turn him away, he will be our enemy. And if he then wins, we're in a mess. And he says, and the quote is, there's only one way to please Caesar and have nothing to fear from Pompey. And he says, and that is, welcome Pompey and kill him. For as we all know, dead men don't bite, which is such a fantastic line.
这不是搞刻板印象。不，好吧，他的行为非常——我对希俄斯一无所知。我的意思是，据我所知，他们可能一点也不油腔滑调——但他表现得很油滑，因为他基本上说：“呃，你知道的，如果我们接纳庞培，我们就成了尤利乌斯·凯撒的敌人，而且庞培会对我们指手画脚、烦人透顶。如果我们把他拒之门外，他就会成为我们的敌人。如果他后来赢了，我们就大难临头了。”接着他说，原话是：“只有一个办法能既取悦凯撒，又不用怕庞培。”他说：“那就是，欢迎庞培，然后杀了他。因为众所周知，死人是不会咬人的。”这台词太妙了。
And then there's this incredible scene, isn't there, where Pompey, who is, as you say, this ancient war hero, he pitches up on his boat. They send a little fishing boat to greet him. The fishing boat has Achillas on, who is Ptolemy's commander, and an old associate of Pompey's called Lucius Septimius, who sort of says, well, he doesn't say anything at first, and Pompey says to him, don't I recognize you?
然后是一个不可思议的场景，不是吗？庞培——正如你所说，这位昔日的战争英雄——乘船抵达。他们派了一艘小渔船去迎接他。渔船上有阿基拉斯（托勒密的统帅），还有一个庞培的老熟人叫卢修斯·塞普蒂米乌斯。他一开始什么也没说，庞培对他说：“我不认识你吗？
You didn't used to be an old comrade of mine. Septimius says yes, and they sail back towards the coast. Pompey's got his speech with him that he's going to read to Ptolemy XIII, this sort of speech of welcome. And it's while he's reading it, I think, that they begin to pull their knives out of the scabbards. And then just as they're approaching the shore, as he can see the boy king on the beach,
你以前不是我的老战友吗？”塞普蒂米乌斯说是的，然后他们一起向海岸驶去。庞培随身带着他准备好要读给托勒密十三世听的演讲稿，那是一种欢迎辞。就在他阅读这份演讲稿的时候，我想，他们开始把匕首从鞘里抽出来了。就在他们接近海岸时，当他能看到海滩上的少年国王时，
surrounded by the oily tutor, the fleshy eunuch and all these these other stereotypes all these other characters they cut pompey's head off what a twist what a twist do you think that's do you think pompey was hard done by there tom i think he had it coming you think he had it coming well i know who else thought i tell you who else thought he had it coming um with the jews because pompe because Pompey had captured Jerusalem and the temple. And of course, no non-Jew was allowed to go into the temple. But Pompey went in and he went right into the Holy of Holies. And the Jews said that from that point on, everything started going wrong for him. out that he'd been uh he'd been beheaded um jewish poets hailed this as um the victory of god over the
周围簇拥着油滑的家庭教师、脑满肠肥的太监以及所有这些其他的刻板形象、所有这些其他角色，他们割下了庞培的头。真是个大反转！真是个大反转！你觉得庞培在那里被坑得很惨吗，托姆？我觉得他咎由自取。你觉得他咎由自取？好吧，我知道还有谁也觉得他咎由自取——犹太人。因为庞培曾攻陷了耶路撒冷和圣殿。当然，非犹太人是不准进入圣殿的。但庞培进去了，他直接走进了至圣所。犹太人说，从那时起，他的一切都开始走下坡路了。当他们发现他被斩首时，
pride of the dragon and said of pompey that he had failed to recognize that god alone is great well so you can see how this this stuff reverberates you know and is interpreted in all kinds of different ways by different peoples um you know this is huge huge stuff uh and of course the the people with whom it reverberates most of all are the romans yeah and specifically julius caesar who's come with a very very light force they're not a large number of men at all in pursuit and he turns up uh in alexandria and he is presented with pompey's head on a kind of silver salver and caesar caesar affects to weep i mean maybe he did we don't know so here's the fascinating thing so caesar has come in pursuit of pompey he gets to alexandria
犹太诗人们将此欢呼为上帝对恶龙骄傲的胜利，并评价庞培说，他没能认识到唯有上帝是伟大的。所以你可以看到这些事情是如何产生回响的（你知道的），并被不同的人群以各种不同的方式解读——你知道的，这可是惊天动地的大事。当然，受其回响影响最深的还是罗马人，是的，尤其是尤利乌斯·凯撒。他只带了一支非常非常轻装的部队，人数绝对不多，一路追击而来。他抵达了亚历山大，呈现在他面前的是用某种银盘装着的庞培的头颅。凯撒假装痛哭流涕——我的意思是，也许他真的哭了，我们不知道。所以，这里有个引人入胜的细节：凯撒为了追击庞培而来到亚历山大，
you know this this sort of strange semi-colony i guess or semi-detached colony or whatever you want to call it on the fringe of the roman sort of the roman imperium but you know the greater city in the world i mean it's larger at this point than Rome. The richest city, exactly. The richest city in the world. So Caesar arrives. It's the first time he's been to Alexandria. This Greek city. He gets off his boat. All these people are there. They say, here's the head of your enemy. We've cut it off for you.
来到了这个奇怪的半殖民地——我猜，或者说罗马帝国边缘的一个半独立殖民地，随便你怎么称呼它——但这可是当时世界上最伟大的城市，我的意思是，它此时的规模比罗马还要大。最富有的城市，没错。世界上最富有的城市。于是凯撒到了。这是他第一次来到亚历山大，这座希腊城市。他下了船。所有这些人都在那里。他们说：“这是你敌人的头颅。我们为你把它割下来了。”
And, yeah, famously, Tom, he starts crying and says, oh, what a terrible shame that he was a Roman. But he's obviously secretly incredibly relieved. Do you think, or do you think, so how seriously does Caesar take this business, this ideological business of he's a Roman, how dare you cut his head off? I think that he feels genuine grief because the men had been close. I think that as a Roman, he thinks it's outrageous that as great a figure as Pompey has been dispatched by people you may well describe as fleshy and oily. I mean,
然后，众所周知，托姆，他开始哭泣，说：“哦，这真是太惨了，他毕竟是个罗马人。”但他心里显然暗自感到极其宽慰。你觉得——或者说你觉得——凯撒对这套意识形态把戏有多认真？“他是个罗马人，你们怎么敢割下他的头？”我认为他感到了真正的悲痛，因为这两个人曾经关系密切。我认为作为一个罗马人，他觉得像庞培这样伟大的人物竟然被你可能会形容为“肥胖且油滑”的人给干掉了，这简直是离谱。我的意思是，
because those are absolutely the terms in which Romans regard sinister kind of Hellenistic Greeks. Tom, I think beheading people on boats is poor form. I'm not going to apologise for dissing Theodotus. You know, the shrewdest political player, one of the shrewdest who's ever lived, of course he understands that this is a godsend because Pompey has been removed, you know, cleared from the chessboard and he's not responsible. Well, Tom, here's the thing.
因为这绝对是罗马人看待阴险的希腊化希腊人的常用词汇。托姆，我觉得在船上斩首别人可真够逊的。我可不会为贬低西奥多图斯道歉。你知道的，作为最精明的政治玩家之一，历史上最精明的政治家之一，他当然明白这是一份天赐的礼物，因为庞培已经被移除了，从棋盘上清理出去了，而且这事又不是他干的。好吧，托姆，关键在于：
You talk about Caesar's shrewdness. So Julius Caesar, we talked about him in the Rubicon podcasts. He's this incredibly experienced, shrewd, cunning, ruthless commander. And now he does something quite odd. So he takes his small forces, you said, and he basically says, let's go to the palace quarter. Let's occupy the palace quarter and establish ourselves there. Even though the Alexandrian crowd are absolutely furious to see him, and clearly the mood of the city is very much against him. And he sort of barricades himself into this sort of compound. Why?
你谈到了凯撒的精明。所以尤利乌斯·凯撒——我们在卢比孔河那期播客里聊过他——他是一位经验极其丰富、精明、狡猾、冷酷无情的统帅。而现在他做了一件相当奇怪的事。他带着你刚才说的那支小部队，基本上说：“我们去王宫区吧。让我们占领王宫区并在那里安营扎寨。”尽管亚历山大的民众看到他时愤怒至极，而且很显然，整座城市的氛围对他是极其敌视的。他把自己像这样 barricaded（筑起街垒）在这个大院里。为什么？
Well, not only that, but he behaves absolutely as a kind of plenipotentiary. He summons both Ptolemy XIII and Cleopatra into his presence, and he is going to decide which of them should rule and what the ordering of Egypt should be. And I think the reason that he does this, well, he needs the money. He also has a civil war. He has a civil war to continue fighting. You know, he's defeated Pompey, but there are plenty of people out there who want to continue the fight against him. So Egypt is very rich and he wants to do what Romans have always done, which is to screw money out of, you know, their hapless underlings. And Caesar claims to be owed money back from, you know, from the days when Ptolemy Aelites, Cleopatra's father, had been handing out bribes in Rome.
不仅如此，他完全表现得像个全权代表。他把托勒密十三世和克娄巴特拉双双召到自己面前，准备由他来裁决究竟该由谁来统治，埃及的秩序又该如何安排。我认为他之所以这么做——好吧，他需要钱。他还有一场内战要打。他还有一场内战要继续打下去。你知道的，他虽然击败了庞培，但外面还有大把的人想要继续与他为敌。所以埃及非常富有，他想做罗马人一直以来都在做的事，那就是从他们倒霉的下属身上榨取钱财。凯撒声称，当年托勒密·奥勒斯（克娄巴特拉的父亲）在罗马大肆行贿时，还欠着他一大笔钱。
Caesar had scooped up a lot and he claimed to be owed even more. So I think that's the reason. The question is, why does he do this when he has so few people at his back? And I think it's just that he's overconfident. And I think that the corollary of that, I think that he takes the Roman stereotyping of Egyptians, literally. He thinks these are effeminate, sinister, decadent, inbred, corrupt people who are simply not worthy of... I don't even need to show them the respect of worrying about what they might do. So, you know, these are not Gauls. He's Vladimir Putin on the night of the 25th of February. Yes. And the truth is that, you know, Caesar fights an enormous number of campaigns
凯撒搜刮了很多，他还声称对方欠他更多。所以我想这就是原因。问题是，为什么在他背后兵力如此薄弱的情况下，他还要这么做？我想这只是因为他太自信了。我认为随之而来的结果是，他把罗马人对埃及人的刻板印象照单全收了。他认为这些人是柔弱、阴险、颓废、近亲繁殖、腐败的人，根本不配——我甚至不需要去顾及他们可能会干出什么事来给他们应有的尊重。所以，你知道，这些人可不是高卢人。他就像2月25日晚上的弗拉基米尔·普京。事实是，你知道的，凯撒在他的职业生涯中打过数量惊人的战役。
over the course of his career. What happens in Alexandria? He comes closest to being defeated and destroyed, closer than at any point in his career that's a brilliant story in itself we'll get to in a second but cleopatra we left her she's got her little army they're out sort of by the delta desperate to get past pelusium this fortress and this army to alexandria and they can't she can't get there he's summoned her but she can't get there. Now, Tom, let's take a break and find out what she does and whether or not it involves a carpet. Let's do that. Okay. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening,
在亚历山大发生了什么？他险些遭到彻底击败和覆灭，比他职业生涯中的任何时刻都更接近绝境。这本身就是一个精彩绝伦的故事，我们一会儿就讲到。但克娄巴特拉——我们之前把她留在那里——她带着她的小军队，驻扎在三角洲附近，拼命想要穿过佩鲁西姆这座要塞和这支军队前往亚历山大，但他们过不去。他召见了她，但她去不了。现在，托姆，我们休息一下，来看看她做了什么，以及这到底包不包含一张地毯。我们这就开始。好的。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告音频、
bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com That's therestisentertainment.com It was night in Alexandria. Darkness had fallen over the greatest city on earth, a black veil of baleful silence. Soldiers patrolled the walls of the palace, spears in hand. It was the late summer of 48 BC, and Alexandria was a city on edge, a powder keg waiting for a spark. In the inky waters of the harbour, a battered little fishing boat rounded the corner and eased towards the shore. Keeping clear of the beam from the great
独家加更节目以及提前抢购现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。那是亚历山大的一个夜晚。夜幕降临在这座世界第一伟大的城市上空，夜色如同一层充满不祥之兆的寂静黑纱。士兵们手持长矛，在宫殿的城墙上巡逻。那是公元前48年的夏末，亚历山大是一座紧张不安的城市，犹如一个一触即发的火药桶。在港口墨黑的水面上，一艘破破烂烂的小渔船绕过转角，向岸边驶去。为了避开伟大的灯塔射出的光束，
lighthouse, the oarsman pulled into the quayside. Working swiftly, he made fast to the jetty, before clambering up the ladder. A bulky bundle on his back. A carpet sack in the darkness it was impossible to be sure so tom holland that was a reading from a fantastic uh children's history of cleopatra which the listeners will not need me to recommend because they've already bought it adventures in time cleopatra queen of the nile by myself but tom uh is Cleopatra in that bag? Well, so we left her, didn't we? At the head of her ragbag of Syrian mercenaries and tribesmen from the Sinai Desert at Pelusium. And Caesar has summoned her and Cleopatra knows that she has to get to Caesar somehow. And so we have this story that's told in Plutarch, although not, interestingly, in Cassius Dio, who's a later historian of this period, actually a historian
船夫将船划向码头。他动作麻利地将船系在栈桥上，然后爬上梯子。他的背上扛着一个笨重的包裹。黑暗中，那是一个地毯袋，实在无法确切辨认——所以，托姆·霍兰，刚才那段朗读节选自一本关于克娄巴特拉的精彩儿童历史书，听众们不需要我来推荐，因为他们已经买过了——《时空历险：尼罗河女王克娄巴特拉》，作者就是区区在下。不过，托姆，克娄巴特拉真的在那个袋子里吗？好吧，所以我们之前把她放在那儿了，不是吗？她率领着她那支由叙利亚雇佣兵和西奈沙漠部落组成的乌合之众，驻扎在佩鲁西姆。而凯撒召见了她，克娄巴特拉深知自己无论如何都必须见到凯撒。于是我们听到了普鲁塔克讲述的这个故事，不过有趣的是，后来的这段历史时期的历史学家卡西乌斯·狄奥并没有提到这个故事——他实际上是整部罗马史的历史学家，但他确实写到了这段时期。
of the whole of Rome, but he writes about this period. And he does not include this story. So that might raise eyebrows, but I think it's true. Plutarch is nearer in time. And the reason I think it's true is that it's true to Cleopatra's character and it's true to Caesar's character. It's the theatricality of it that is the key, isn't it? So the tradition is that presumably Cleopatra kind of goes down. She sneaks past. She goes down the Nile. She brought up the Nile to Alexandria and then smuggled in, in what is traditionally described as a carpet.
而他并没有收录这个故事。所以这可能会让人起疑，但我认为它是真的。普鲁塔克距离当时的时间更近。而且我认为它是真的，是因为它符合克娄巴特拉的性格，也符合凯撒的性格。关键在于它的戏剧性，对吧？所以按传统说法，大概是克娄巴特拉独自前去。她悄悄潜行过去。她顺着尼罗河而下，乘船来到亚历山大，然后被偷运进来，装在通常被描述为地毯的东西里。
But that's a 19th century translation of Plutarch. It wasn't a carpet. It's probably a linen bag or something. A kind of bag for carrying bed linen or maybe even a matting bed roll, something like that. But the story is that this gets brought into Caesar's presence and Cleopatra kind of emerges either from the role or from the bag or whatever. And people have said, well, this wouldn't have happened because
但那是19世纪对普鲁塔克的翻译。那根本不是地毯。那可能是一个亚麻袋之类的东西。一个用来装床单的袋子，或者甚至是一个草垫卷，诸如此类。但故事说，这个东西被带到了凯撒面前，克娄巴特拉从那个卷轴、袋子或者其他什么东西里钻了出来。有人说，这绝不可能发生，因为
she was incredibly conscious of her dignity. She would never introduce herself like this. And that's true. Of course, Cleopatra has an incredible sense of her dignity, but more than that, she has an understanding of what makes people she wants to impress tick. And she will have studied Caesar and she will have appreciated that he's an intelligent man with a taste for the kind of stunt that she's about to pull. And I think that it's evident that Caesar immediately takes Cleopatra's side. In his long years of adventure, Julius Caesar had seen many things, but this was something beyond even his experience. The woman smiled.
她对自己的尊严极其珍视。她绝不会以这种方式自我介绍。这倒也没错。当然，克娄巴特拉有着极强的尊严感，但不仅如此，她还深谙如何拿捏那些她想要打动的人的心理。她一定研究过凯撒，并且料定这是一个聪明、且有品味去欣赏她即将上演的这种恶作剧的男人。显而易见，凯撒立刻站到了克娄巴特拉这一边。在漫长的冒险岁月里，尤利乌斯·凯撒见过许多大风大浪，但这甚至超出了他的经验范畴。那名女子微微一笑。
Greetings, Commander, she said sweetly. I am Cleopatra. Brilliant, Dominic. I'm sure it was exactly like that. I mean, the problem is that Caesar himself, so in the commentaries that Caesar writes and that are then after his murder written up by his lieutenants, Caesar barely mentions Cleopatra. Shocking.
“向您致敬，统帅，”她甜美地说，“我是克娄巴特拉。”太妙了，多米尼克。我敢说当时的情景绝对就是这样。我的意思是，问题在于凯撒本人——所以在凯撒自己写的战地札记中，以及在他遇刺后由他的副将们整理出版的著作中，凯撒几乎没有提到克娄巴特拉。这太令人震惊了。
Just as he doesn't mention crossing the Rubicon either in his commentaries. There are certain things that he doesn't want to draw attention to and he doesn't want to draw attention to his relationship with Cleopatra. Equally, of course, Cleopatra does because very, very rapidly Cleopatra gets pregnant. And we can only assume that this is absolutely deliberate on the parts of both of them. Well, let's just pause a second. She's about 21. He is 52.
正如他在战地札记中也绝口不提自己跨越卢比孔河一样。有些事情是他不想引起注意的，他不想让人注意到他和克娄巴特拉的关系。同样，克娄巴特拉当然希望引起注意，因为克娄巴特拉很快就怀孕了。我们只能认为这完全是他们两人深思熟虑的结果。好吧，我们暂停一下。她大约21岁，而他52岁。
So that's quite an age gap. But is it, I mean, it's obviously not a love affair, but it's, you know she's 21 she's presumably reasonably attractive at least um you know plutarch in his description he doesn't say he says she's not a mess that astoundingly beautiful but he doesn't say you know she's not going to drive you running out of the room um julius caesar has an eye for the ladies anyway doesn't he's notorious for it he's a he's he's a he's a sort of bad boy yeah so and she knows so he's the first man that she's he's her first boyfriend as it were um and she's not approaching this as this sort of i mean there's this line that her brother's ministers put about that she's captured the old man by magic but she
所以年龄差距确实挺大。但这——这显然不是什么浪漫恋情，但你知道的，她21岁，至少长得大概还算迷人吧——你知道的，普鲁塔克在描述她时并没有说——他说她并非那种惊艳绝伦的美人，但他也没有说她会让你吓得夺门而出。反正尤利乌斯·凯撒对女人一向很有眼光，不是吗？他在这方面可是出了名的坏小子。所以她深知——他是她第一个真正意义上的男朋友，而且她并没有以那种——我的意思是，她弟弟的大臣们散布谣言说她用魔法迷住了这个老头，但她
must know exactly i mean she's doing this old man by magic but she must know exactly i mean she's doing this politically right it's not a romance i think i think that they must they must there must have been an attraction between them they obviously both liked each other yeah and in a way the whole kind of coming out of a sack stunt is cleopatra's tribute to to what a you know what an amusing and and smart guy ca Caesar is. So I think there's absolutely that dimension. But both of them have a kind of mutuality of interests because Caesar suddenly realizes that he's surrounded by a howling mob. And so Achillas, Ptolemy XIII general is on the outside, Pothinus is inside. But he realizes that probably the best bet is to get rid of Ptolemy XIII, put Cleopatra as a puppet. And if he can
一定非常清楚——我的意思是，她这么做完全是出于政治考量，对吧？这并不是一场浪漫恋爱。我认为他们之间——他们之间肯定存在某种吸引力。他们显然都挺喜欢对方的。某种程度上，从麻袋里钻出来的这出把戏，正是克娄巴特拉对凯撒这种幽默且聪明的男人的致敬。所以我觉得绝对有这方面的因素。但他们两个有着共同的利益诉求，因为凯撒突然意识到自己被愤怒的暴民包围了。托勒密十三世的将军阿基拉斯在外面，波提努斯在里面。他意识到，或许最好的对策就是除掉托勒密十三世，扶植克娄巴特拉当傀儡。如果他能
get Cleopatra pregnant and establish a dynasty, then that's brilliant because that gets around the whole problem of what his relationship to Egypt should be because if if his son is really egypt then obviously that's great i mean that cuts through the whole gordian knot of what the constitutional proprieties should be for a republican general though of course that's a problem in rome isn't it caesar's married already to calpurnia it will be but i don't think that that unduly worries him because there are many different ways of kind of spinning this. Equally for Cleopatra, she has clearly decided that Caesar is, you know, is going to, is the guy to back. She doesn't really have any option but to do that.
让克娄巴特拉怀孕并建立一个王朝，那就太棒了，因为这能完美避开关于他与埃及关系性质的所有难题——如果他的儿子实际上就代表了埃及，那显然太妙了。我的意思是，这直接斩断了共和制统帅在宪政正统性上面临的戈耳狄俄斯之结。当然，这在罗马是个问题，不是吗？凯撒已经和卡尔普尼娅结婚了。这以后会是个问题，但我认为这不会给他带来太多困扰，因为有很多不同的方式可以来粉饰这一点。对克娄巴特拉而言同样如此，她显然已经下定决心，凯撒就是她应该押宝的那个人。她其实也别无选择。
And if she can establish a dynastic link to the guy who may well end up ruling Rome, then obviously that's brilliant for her. And of course, her primary object at this point is to get rid of her brother. So we're in late 48 BC. Pompey's dead. They are in the sort of palace quarter of Alexandria. It's this sort of walled compound, I guess, or at least they've put up barricades or something. Yes, it serves as a fortress. To stop the population breaking in and Achillas' army. And then, I mean, you said earlier this really interesting thing, that this is the closest that Julius Caesar comes in his entire military career to disaster because he's got the small force. They're besieged because the siege goes on for basically,
如果她能与这个很可能最终统治罗马的男人建立起王朝纽带，那对她而言显然是绝佳的。当然，她此时的首要目标就是除掉她的弟弟。所以我们来到了公元前48年底。庞培已死。他们身处亚历山大的王宫区。那是一个带围墙的大院，我猜，或者至少他们建起了街垒之类的东西。是的，它被当作一座要塞来使用。为了阻止民众冲进来，也为了抵挡阿基拉斯的军队。然后，我的意思是，你刚才说了那个极其有趣的细节：这是尤利乌斯·凯撒整个军事生涯中最接近毁灭的一次，因为他只有一支小部队。他们被围困了，因为这场围城战基本上持续了
it's about six months or so, isn't it? Yeah, and he's stuck there and he doesn't know what's going on in the broader strategic sphere of the Mediterranean. I mean, he's got all those enemies out there. It's a disaster for him. And at one point, he has to burn his own fleet to stop the enemy getting hold of it. And in the course of that, they accidentally burn down part of the Great Library. I mean, this is one of the...
大约半年左右，不是吗？是的，他被困在那里，对地中海更广阔的战略局势一无所知。我的意思是，外面有那么多敌人。对而言他是一场灾难。在某个时刻，他甚至不得不烧毁自己的舰队以防落入敌人手中。在这个过程中，他们不小心烧毁了亚历山大图书馆的一部分。我的意思是，这是——
Yeah, hugely. Or is this an urban myth, Tom? Historians are divided about this, aren't they? It's much, much debated. I think we should do an episode on the Library of Alexandria. It's an incredibly much debated. I think we should do an episode on the library of Alexandria. It's an incredibly complicated, but fascinating story.
是的，影响极其深远。还是说这只是个都市传说，托姆？历史学家对此意见不一，不是吗？这引发了非常激烈的争论。我想我们应该专门做一期关于亚历山大图书馆的节目。这是一个极其复杂的，但又无比迷人的故事。
Yeah. And the mysteries that surround it are part of the fascination. but it's possible anyway, that part of it was destroyed. Yeah. Um, then, and this incredibly convoluted story.
是的。围绕它的种种谜团正是其魅力的一部分。但无论如何，其中一部分被毁是有可能的。是的。然后，这个极其错综复杂的故事还在继续。
So at one point they're there in the palace, the Caesar, there's Ptolemy the 13th. There is Cleopatra. Pothinus. Yes. And there is her youngest sister. Ophidus. Yes. And there is her younger sister, Arsinoe. Yes, who's a baggage. Well, she's a teenager, isn't she?
所以有一段时间，他们都在王宫里：凯撒、托勒密十三世、克娄巴特拉、波提努斯——是的——还有她的小妹妹。奥菲杜斯？——是的。还有她较小的妹妹阿尔西诺伊。是的，那是个小祸害。好吧，她还是个十几岁的少女，不是吗？
She must be about 18 or 19. Yeah, she's terrible. But is she, though, Tom? So what Arsinoe does, Arsinoe basically breaks out of the palace with her tutor, who's called Ganymede. And they then go and join the rioters. And she sets herself up as a rival, doesn't she? She's obviously incredibly jealous of her. She is the Prince Harry of that family.
她大概18、19岁吧。是的，她太可怕了。不过，托姆，真的是这样吗？阿尔西诺伊做了什么呢？阿尔西诺伊基本上和她的家庭教师加尼米德一起逃出了王宫。然后他们去加入了起义者，她把自己树立为一个竞争对手，不是吗？她显然对克娄巴特拉嫉妒得要命。她简直就是那个家族里的哈里王子。
She's the Princess Margaret. She's the Princess Margaret. Right. Well, anyway. They're all awful. They're all murderous. I always kind of think of her as the archetype of the awful little sister, who's kind of jealous of the high achieving elder sister, resentful and jealous and always trying to kind of stab her in the back and ruin things for her.
她是玛格丽特公主。她就是玛格丽特公主。好吧，总之。他们都糟糕透顶。他们都是些杀人狂。我总是把她视作那种讨厌的小妹妹的原型——嫉妒心强、怨气冲天、满心怨恨，总是试图在背后捅刀子，把事情搞砸。
So she's got out. But then Ptolemy, he says, let me go and talk to them. You know, and he says to Julius Caesar, I've learned so much from you. I think you're such a tremendous fellow. I really respect you. Please let me go outside and reason with the rioters. And he goes out to reason with them, but then he sort of turns around and says, I hate you. And he joins them as well. So now it's just Caesar and Cleopatra left in the palace. But Caesar's executed Pothinus. Yes, he's executed Pothinus with his men. And they're trapped and everybody is against them. And there's all these strange stories about they poison the water supply or they put salt or something in the water.
所以她逃出去了。但接着，托勒密说，让我去和他们谈谈。你知道的，他对尤利乌斯·恺撒说，我从你身上学到了太多。我觉得你是个了不起的人。我真的很尊敬你。请让我出去和暴徒讲道理。他出去和他们讲道理，但随后他转过身说，我恨你们。他也加入了他们的阵营。所以现在宫殿里只剩下恺撒和克娄巴特拉了。但恺撒处决了波提努斯。是的，他和他的手下处决了波提努斯。他们被困住了，所有人都与他们为敌。还有各种离奇的传言，说他们给供水系统下毒，或者在水里加了盐之类的东西。
Caesar loses his Red General's cloak. Yeah, Caesar goes out to do some stuff in the harbour and is almost caught and killed. And actually, he's bailed out, isn't he, by a relief army. I mean, he doesn't actually win the day. Yeah, but led by a kind of Greek potentate, Mithridates of Pergamon. Right. You know, mildly humiliating, but Caesar doesn't care. Because essentially, that enables him to redeem the situation. And Ptolemy XIII ends up drowned. And Cleopatra is now kind of secure so she then marries her youngest brother
恺撒弄丢了他的红色将军斗篷。是的，恺撒去港口办点事，差一点被抓并丧命。实际上，他是被一支救援部队救了，对吧？我的意思是，他并没有真正打赢这一仗。是的，但这支军队由一个类似希腊诸侯的人物——帕加マ的米特里达梯率领。没错。你知道，这有点羞辱性，但恺撒并不在乎。因为本质上，这使他能够挽回局面。而十三世托勒密最终溺水身亡。克娄巴特拉现在算是安全了，于是她嫁给了她的小弟弟
who becomes Ptolemy the 14th as if we hadn't got enough Ptolemies already another one another one um and Caesar and Cleopatra go on a barge it said and they kind of go on a trip down the Nile well this is number so we've had the carpet and this is probably the next great set piece in the sort of Hollywood version of Cleopatra's life, isn't it? So they go on this cruise, one of probably history's most famous cruise. Yeah, probably, yeah. So they go on this sort of Nile cruise,
他成了托勒密十四世，仿佛我们还嫌托勒密不够多似的一又来了一个又来了一个嗯，据说恺撒和克娄巴特拉坐上了一艘驳船，他们顺着尼罗河泛舟而下，好吧，这就是——我们之前谈过地毯，这可能是好莱坞版克娄巴特拉生平中的下一个高潮戏码，对吧？所以他们去巡游了，这可能是历史上最著名的巡游之一。是的，很可能是。所以他们进行了这次尼罗河巡游，
and they look at the pyramids and inspect wildlife. And actually, historians have always said, what on earth is Julius Caesar doing? He's meant to be fighting a civil war. And he's sort of gone off on this pleasure barge up the Nile. So what do you think is going on there, Tom? I think that Caesar is buying into Cleopatra's idea of a dynasty that will be properly rooted in the affections of the Egyptians. Yeah. And I think he's playing his part in that. So Cleopatra going down the Nile, which is the source of life in Egypt.
他们观看金字塔并考察野生动物。事实上，历史学家们一直都在说，尤利乌斯·恺撒到底在干什么？他本该去打内战的。而他却乘着这艘游船逆尼罗河而上。汤姆，你觉得当时发生了什么？我认为恺撒是在认可克娄巴特拉的设想，即建立一个真正扎根于埃及人民情感的王朝。是的。我认为他在其中扮演了自己的角色。所以克娄巴特拉顺尼罗河而下，这是埃及生命之源。
And she is claiming to be the goddess who manifests herself, the giver of life, the giver of fertility. That's what she's doing. She's presenting herself to her people as an authentically Egyptian pharaoh. So Caesar is buying into that. And this is why he can't mention it in his commentaries, because basically he's recognized in these kind of dynastic links that he can have with Cleopatra, that it's a form of power that is not available to any other Roman, simply because of his circumstances. So I think that's what he's doing. It's something he
而她自称是显现神迹的女神，是生命之源，是繁衍之源。这就是她在做的事。她把自己作为一位地地道道的埃及法老呈现给她的子民。所以恺撒对此表示认可。这就是为什么他在自己的回忆录中绝口不提此事，因为基本上，他通过与克娄巴特拉建立的这种王朝纽带意识到，这是一种其他任何罗马人都无法拥有的权力形式，纯粹是因为他的处境。所以我想这就是他在做的事。这是他
absolutely wants to keep quiet. He's not going to trumpet it in Rome because no one would approve. But if his son comes to be accepted as a pharaoh ruling in association with her mother, then that is a massive, massive asset for Caesar. And so he establishes that. And then having done that, he sails off,
绝对想要保密的事。他不会在罗马大肆宣扬，因为没有人会赞同。但如果他的儿子被承认为与她母亲联合统治的法老，那么对恺撒来说，这将是一笔巨大无比的财富。因此他确立了这一点。做完这些后，他扬帆起航，
comes, sees, conquers. This is, you know, Veni, Vidi, Vici. This is- Because he goes off to Asia Minor, doesn't he? Yeah, and then having done that he sails off comes sees conquers uh this is you know veni vidivici this is because he goes off to asia minor doesn't yeah and gets that then he he defeats all his various republican enemies he goes back to rome um and he celebrates various triumphs and among these triumphs is he celebrates an egyptian triumph and in the triumph he leads cleopatra's younger sister yeah the young arsinoe. And this isn't popular. The Roman people don't like seeing her led in chains. Yeah, because they cheer her or they applaud her or something. They applaud her, yeah.
来，看，征服。这就是，你知道的，我来，我见，我征服。这是——因为他去了小亚细亚，对吧？是的，然后做完这些他扬帆起航，来，看，征服，呃，这就是，你知道的，我来，我见，我征服，这是因为他去了小亚细亚，对不对？是的，赢得了胜利，然后他击败了所有形形色色的共和派敌人，他回到了罗马，嗯，他庆祝了多场凯旋式，而在这些凯旋式中，他庆祝了一场埃及凯旋式，在凯旋式中他游街示众了克娄巴特拉更年轻的妹妹，对吧，年轻的阿尔西诺伊。这并不受欢迎。罗马人民不喜欢看到她戴着铁链游街。是的，因为他们为她欢呼或是鼓掌之类的。他们为她鼓掌，对吧。
And Cleopatra is now unchallenged. She has a much younger brother who is now her husband, Ptolemy the 14th. She has given birth in June 47 to a son who she calls Ptolemy Caesar. So it's completely upfront that this is Julius. Caesar doesn't acknowledge the child, but the name is the giveaway. But Caesar does invite her to Rome. So she comes to rome with her husband who is also her brother yeah and it's all very very un-roman so caesar puts them up doesn't he in his estate in osnabrück across the tiber yeah um and is she there tom do you think
而克娄巴特拉现在已经地位稳固、无人挑战。她有一个小得多的弟弟，现在成了她的丈夫，即托勒密十四世。她在公元前47年6月生下一个儿子，她给他取名叫托勒密·恺撒。所以这完全是公开的，这就是尤利乌斯。恺撒没有承认这个孩子，但名字说明了一切。不过恺撒确实邀请她去了罗马。所以她带着丈夫——也就是她的弟弟——来到了罗马，是的，这一切都非常非常不罗马化，所以恺撒把他们安置在台伯河对岸奥斯纳布吕克的庄园里，嗯，汤姆，你觉得她去那里
to see because historians are not quite sure the dates but do you think she was there to see his triumphs do you think would that be interesting to isn't it? It's interesting to know if, whether she put Caesar up to having her sister. Yeah. I mean, so I've seen a way, does she, she gets spared and I think gets settled at Ephesus,
是为了看——因为历史学家们对具体日期不太确定，但你觉得她是去那里看他的凯旋式吗？你觉得这会不会很有趣？了解一下她是否怂恿恺撒处理掉她的妹妹，这很有意思，不是吗？我的意思是，我看到的一种说法是，她被饶恕了，并且我想是在以弗所安顿下来了，
isn't it? After the, after the triumph, but Cleopatra certainly, she kind of beds down and is very grand dame and Cicero, the great orator, great kind of intellectual she he's terribly resentful of her so alexandria is actually the only place that cicero said he wanted
对吧？在凯旋式之后，但克娄巴特拉当然，她安顿下来，摆出了极具大贵妇的架势，而伟大的演说家、伟大的知识分子西塞罗，他对她极为怨恨，所以亚历山大实际上是西塞罗说他唯一想去的地方
to visit apart from rome is that so you know he was a he he said alexandria is the one place i want to visit but he goes to see claire patra and gets snubbed by her and so he's he's very he well he obviously there's some source isn't there where he writes he says i hate the queen i hate her um do you know what you want to do you want to know how our top children's book describes cicero from cleopatra's point of view yeah i'd love to hear that yeah a jowly toad-faced man smooth and silver-tongued but monstrously vain and pompous yeah well nothing wrong with being monstrously vain rain and pompous so so clay patras there with cesarean her son her young son and her brother who is her husband it's all it's all
除了罗马，是这样吗？你知道，他曾说——他说亚历山大是我唯一想去的地方，但他去见克娄巴特拉却被她冷落了，所以他非常——嗯，他显然有某种资料来源，他在其中写道，我恨女王，我恨她，你知道你想做什么吗？你想知道我们顶级儿童读物是如何从克娄巴特拉的角度来描述西塞罗的吗？是的，我很想听听。好吧，一个腮帮肥大、满脸横肉、巧舌如簧却又虚荣自大、自命不凡的男人。好吧，虚荣自大和自命不凡也没什么错。所以，克娄巴特拉和恺撒里昂——她的儿子、她的小儿子以及她的丈夫——都在那里，这一切都
very odd and they come and go a little bit don't they tom in the next couple of years are they sort of she's there in 46 bc and then she's there again when you know we're jumping ahead when caesar finally gets the really does get the boot she is and and then she has she when, you know, we're jumping ahead, when Caesar finally gets the, really does get the boot. She is. And then she has, she basically, you know, Rome is obviously no place for her. Yeah. After her protector is dead.
非常诡异，在接下来的几年里，他们也来来往往，不是吗，汤姆？她在公元前46年待在那儿，然后当——我们把时间跳到后面——恺撒最终真正被赶下台时，她又在那儿了。她是。然后她——当，你知道的，我们把时间跳到后面，当恺撒最终真正被赶下台时。她是。然后她——基本上，你知道的，罗马显然已经没有她的容身之所了。是的。在她的保护人死后。
And so she flees back to Alexandria. So there's obviously during this whole period, Caesar has won the civil war. There is this sort of mounting tension in Rome, the sense that he's going to set himself up as a king and all this sort of business. He's too powerful. He's too domineering. And do you think her presence is part of that? Yeah, I do. So no one's quite sure what Caesar's going to do. I don't think Caesar knows what he's
于是她逃回了亚历山大。所以在整个这段时间里，显而易见的是，恺撒赢得了内战。罗马国内有一种不断加剧的紧张气氛，人们觉得他要把自己立为国王，诸如此类。他太强大了，太专横了。你认为她的存在是其中的一部分吗？是的，我这么认为。所以没有人确切知道恺撒要做什么。我不认为恺撒知道他要
going to do. So he's planning to go on an attack path here, which is the great empire, the only real kind of empire that survives as a rival to Rome. And I think he's going there basically because he's not quite sure what to do. But it's evident, I think, that the kind of dynastic model of rulership that the Ptolemies represent, the kind of Hellenistic tradition of monarchical rule is of interest to Caesar. He knows that the Romans would never accept it because it's a republic and the name king is absolutely dirty to them. But I think it's kind of hovering there as something that he is tempted to make play with. And I think that Cleopatra's presence in Rome is a kind of marker of that. And to that extent, encourages the assassins who end
做什么。所以他正计划在这里开辟一条进攻路线，即那个伟大的帝国，唯一作为罗马竞争对手存活下来的真正的帝国。我想他去那里基本上是因为他不太确定该做什么。但很明显，我认为托勒密家族所代表的这种王朝统治模式、这种君主统治的希腊化传统对恺撒很具有吸引力。他知道罗马人绝不会接受这一点，因为这是一个共和国，而“国王”这个名号对他们来说绝对是十恶不赦的。但我认为它就像某种悬而未决的事物，让他跃跃欲试。我认为克娄巴特拉在罗马的存在就是这种倾向的一个标志。从这个角度来看，这也鼓励了最终在马月节（Ides of March）刺杀他的刺客们，
up murdering him on the the eyes of march which is why cleopatra has no stake at all in staying in rome after caesar murdered and when he's when he's dead she you know she goes skedaddling back to alexandria as fast as she can go so back she goes to alexandria when she kills ptolemy the yeah the 14th so that's him gone and now she's ruling with Caesarian, who is, what, three or something? So why does she kill her brother? That's a really, I mean, that's the most, in all her career, that's probably the single most ruthless and sort of jarring thing that she does.
正因如此，克娄巴特拉在恺撒被刺杀后完全没有留在罗马的理由，当他死了之后，她以最快的速度溜回了亚历山大。所以她回到了亚历山大，在那里她杀死了托勒密——是的，第十四世，所以他被除掉了，现在她和恺撒里昂一起统治，后者当时几岁来着，三岁左右？所以她为什么要杀她的弟弟？这真的是——我的意思是，在她的整个职业生涯中，这可能是她做过的最冷酷无情、最让人大跌眼镜的事了。
She kills her. It's not jarring. It's absolutely. Or jarring to modern sensibilities, Tom. I mean, murdering your brother is. You know, her ambition is to, and not just to rule, but to reconstitute the Ptolemaic Empire, to take it back to its former state of greatness.
她杀了他。这并不让人大跌眼镜。这绝对是——或者说对现代人的情感而言是大跌眼镜的，汤姆。我的意思是，谋杀你的弟弟。你知道，她的野心是，不仅要统治，还要重建托勒密帝国，让它恢复到昔日的伟大状态。
She can't do that if she has a kind of little brother breathing down her neck, because that little brother will become the thing of rivals to her. So the equivalents of people like ekelas and pathenus yeah we'll take we'll we'll use him as a cipher to strike back at her and whereas whereas her her own son obviously will be massively under her thumb and of course she's going to get rid of the situation in rome makes it all the more imperative to do that because her protector in rome is dead yeah the roman world is slipping into civil war so the presence of an alternative you know is she can't afford to have him hanging around i mean i said it was jarring it's not jarring to anybody
如果有个小弟弟对她纠缠不休，她就无法做到这一点，因为那个小弟弟会成为对抗她的竞争对手的化身。因此，像阿基拉斯和波提努斯这样的人的同类，是的，我们会利用他、把她当成打击她的傀儡，而与此同时，她自己的儿子显然会完全听命于她，而且她当然要摆脱罗马的局势，这使得这样做更加刻不容缓，因为她在罗马的保护人已经死了，是的，罗马世界正在滑向内战。因此，存在一个替代人选（你知道的），她承担不起让他四处晃悠的后果。我的意思是，我刚才说这让人大跌眼镜，但对于任何了解托勒密王朝历史的人来说，这一点也不让人大跌眼镜，
who knows the history of the ptolemaic dynasty because obviously the lesson of ptolemaic history is you you do it and you're right to do it yeah cleopatra killed him and she was right to kill him yeah it was the only sane thing to do it was the only thing because of course she is back in egypt but meanwhile as in her early the early years of her reign so now the context for what she is doing in egypt is set by the the threat of civil war in rome and by extension the whole of the mediterranean and that is the context for what i think should be episode three. I think we should halt now. And episode three, we should look at what happens with the civil war between Caesar's assassins and Caesar's avengers and the Roman leaders who emerged from that and what their
因为很显然，托勒密历史的教训就是：你得这么做，而且你这么做是对的。是的，克娄巴特拉杀了他，她杀他是对的。这是唯一理智的做法，这是唯一的做法，因为当然，她回到了埃及，与此同时，在她统治的早期——现在她统治埃及的背景由罗马乃至整个地中海的内战威胁所设定，我认为这就是第三期节目的背景。我想我们现在应该停在这里。在第三期节目中，我们应该探讨恺撒的刺客与恺撒的复仇者之间爆发内战时发生了什么，以及由此崛起罗马领袖与克娄巴特拉的关系是什么。
relationship to Cleopatra is. Excellent. So if you're part of the Rest is History Club, you can go straight to episode three right now. If you're not, you can either sign up at restishistorypod.com or you'll have to wait until whenever it is that we release episode three um but uh we will see you then for more cleopatra based action bye-bye bye-bye Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening,
太棒了。因此，如果您是“历史其余部分”俱乐部的成员，您可以立刻前往收听第三期节目。如果不是，您可以在 restishistorypod.com 注册，或者您只能等到我们发布第三期节目的那一刻了，不过，呃，我们到时见，会有更多关于克娄巴特拉的精彩内容。拜拜，拜拜。感谢收听《历史其余部分》。想要获取独家单集、抢先收听、无广告收听，
and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐其余部分》。这是您每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论和八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果您想享受无广告收听、独家单集以及抢先购买现场门票的特权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。